und damit kommen wir zur nächsten
einzelplan ernährung und landwirtschaft
in einzelplan 10 ist das 7 1 milliarden
euro soll
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister cem
özdemir in diesem jahr bekommen der
haushaltsausschuss hat in seiner
bereinigungssitzung seinen etat ein
wenig gekürzt also ein wenig in
anführungsstrichen
244.000 euro weniger soll es geben
trotzdem ist das natürlich viel geld das
unter anderem eingesetzt werden soll zum
beispiel
der fischerei betrieben zu helfen weil
doch die fangquoten deutlich reduziert
werden aber der größte teil geht wie
auch im vergangenen jahr für die renten-
und krankenversicherung der landwirte
dabei auf
3,95 milliarden euro sind dafür
eingeplant um dort die landwirte zu
unterstützen in ihrer alterssicherung
und in der krankenversicherung außerdem
sollen die landwirte auch über die
sozialversicherung hilfen bekommen die
bis september
2022 ausgezahlt werden und natürlich
auch seit jahren eigentlich ein thema
das tierwohl label soll endlich kommen
noch in diesem jahr so haben es die
koalitionsparteien in ihren
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
ich denke wir können dort ein bisschen
skeptisch sein weil das tierwohl label
nun wirklich schon seit einigen jahren
angekündigt wird aber vielleicht werden
wir eines besseren belehrt bundes
gesundheitsberatung
bundesernährungsministerium özdemir wird
auch noch sprechen aber erst einmal
redet josef rief zu diesem einzel liter
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen sehr
geehrter herr minister die erste frage
lautet was können wir tun um die
katastrophe ausgelöst durch putins
angriffskrieg wenigstens zu lindern und
die dramatische ernährungssituation in
afrika zu verbessern herr minister was
machen sie bisher wenig bis nichts nein
sie stehen vernünftige lösungen sogar im
weg wenn sie etwas tun wollen nicht
gehen sie noch heute in ihr ministerium
und lassen den pflanzenschutz bei
pflanzen auf vorrang brechen zu die
mehrerträge auf den knapp 100.000 hektar
entsprechen 100 millionen kilogramm die
3d äquivalent allein damit könnten wir
eine million menschen ein jahr lang mit
brot versorgen
und wenn sie früher dran gewesen wären
wären es sogar mindestens doppelt so
viel die eu lässt das zu österreich zum
beispiel macht es andere länder machen
ist sie machen nichts kommen sie mir
nicht mit dem argument sie lassen die
ökologischen vorrangflächen für futter
zwecke zu das war schon in den trockenen
jahren 2018 und 2019 möglich und wird
geradezu lächerlich angesichts dieser
herausforderungen und wenn wir als
grünland nur für wenige jahre um brechen
würden könnten wir zusätzlich mehrere
millionen menschen mit brotgetreide
versorgen auch hier das gleiche die eu
ist zu in deutschland passiert nichts
und es würde nicht mal etwas kosten was
können wir eigentlich von ihnen erwarten
haben nicht
wenn es um die geplanten vier prozent
stilllegungen ab kommenden jahr geht das
muss man der bevölkerung einmal erklären
wie beklagen den mangel an weltweite
weizenproduktion das
welternährungsprogramm warnt vor einer
hungerkatastrophe ich darauf die reden
ihre ministerinnen hinweisen und
gleichzeitig legen wir ab 2023 4%
ackerfläche still dazu tragen wir dazu
bei dass millionen menschen besonders in
afrika sie hier tägliches brot nicht
mehr leisten können und hungern müssen
um nicht falsch verstanden zu warten
ökologische ziele sind wichtig sie
willkommen aber zu westlicher dekadenz
wenn große teile der weltbevölkerung in
folge des 24 februars von hunger bedroht
sind stattdessen
schlagen sie vor
die fruchtfolge zu ändern und stoppel
weizen anzubauen
mit ein wenig sachverstand weiß man wo
es möglich ist in deutschland wird dies
längst gemacht ansonsten ist es unsinnig
und führt zu mindererträgen
und es muss auch endlich schluss sein
mit dem fleisch bashing die tiere sind
nicht unmittelbar nahrungskonkurrenten
wie sie es haben nicht bald in jeder
rede behaupten sie wissen genau dass nur
ein teil des brot getreides brot
qualität hat nicht überall ist es
möglich arbeiten zu anfang und unsere
nutztiere verwandeln für den menschen
kaum verwertbare pflanzen in wertvolle
nahrungsmittel und jeder der sich
ernsthaft damit befasst weiß und ich
finde das mal genau zuzuhören das für
jedes kilo pflanzliche nahrung dass auf
dem teller landet circa vier kilo
biomasse mit produziert worden die wir
als menschen nicht verwerten können
deshalb gehört ihr haltung seit
jahrtausenden zum menschen und aus
diesem grund können sie ja auch die 35
millionen haustiere übrigens genauso
viele rinder und schweine gibt es in
deutschland darauf verlassen dass auch
für sie wir künftig wieder bereitstellen
damit sie ihre wichtigen funktionen
erfüllen können
nutztierhaltung nützt grünland und für
den menschen nicht die eigene
futtermitteln und hilft mit
wirtschaftsdünger zusätzliche
hochwertige nahrungsmittel zu erzeugen
all diese probleme bildet die haushalt
nicht ab sie haben den etat um fast 7,4
prozent gekürzt gleichzeitig steigen die
personalkosten um sage und schreibe 65
innerhalb millionen euro es ist luft im
haushalt trotzdem können sie den
zuschuss zur unfallversicherung
das belastet die landwirte mit
mindestens 18%
beitragszuschuss zur
berufsgenossenschaft die müssen also 18
prozentpunkte mehr bezahlen ich glaube
in dieser zeit ist das völlig falsche
signal sie alle meine sehr geehrten
damen und hand können jetzt noch unsere
anhänger und der anhebung zustimmen
unser antrag liegt vor stimmen sie
einfach für ihn ich danke ihnen haben
die stadt möchte ich auch sagen dass sie
die 60 millionen hilfsgelder der eu mit
120 millionen aufstocken doch
ackerbaubetriebe und die milchviehhalter
sollen leer ausgehen wir würden über die
förderung des agrardiesels alle bauern
bei den gestiegenen energiekosten
entlasten hast
das investitionsprogramm landwirtschaft
haben sie um 360 millionen und weitere
vier millionen abgesenkt das
bundesprogramm ländliche entwicklung
wurde ebenfalls verringern verringert
kürzungen mit ausgabe rechten aus dem
krone hat zu begründen ist zwar
nachvollziehbar wir hätten es aber im
gegensatz zu ihnen den bauern an anderer
stelle zurückgegeben ihr haushalt man
nicht derzeit mit den reduzierungen aber
den stellenwert der landwirtschaft in
der ampel ihre ankündigung zum tierwohl
sucht man vergebens sinnvolle erhöhungen
wie bei der gemeinschaftsaufgabe
agrarstruktur und küstenschutz stammen
noch aus der alten regierung wollen sie
ihrer verantwortung gerecht die
katastrophalen auswirkungen des krieges
tatsächlich zu bekämpfen und die bauern
und den ländlichen raum voranzubringen
dafür bitte ich sie ganz herzlich hat
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
josef rief hat es hier angekündigt die
unionsfraktion hat ihr einen
änderungsantrag eingebracht in dem sie
fordert dass die zuschüsse zur
landwirtschaftlichen unfallversicherung
noch einmal erhöht werden nach dieser
debatte werden die abgeordneten über
diesen änderungsantrag abstimmen bis der
redner ist sebastian schäfer
obmann im haushaltsausschuss
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen diesen
bundeshaushalt stellen wir in einer zeit
multiple krisen auf die pandemie ist
noch nicht vorbei und hat jetzt schon
jetzt einen gravierenden
volkswirtschaftlichen schaden
hinterlassen der russische angriffskrieg
gegen die ukraine geht unvermindert mit
voller härte weiter und verursacht
großes leid vor ort wir stehen dadurch
als bundesrepublik vor immensen
wirtschaftlichen problemen und natürlich
haben wir die menschheitsaufgabe
lösungswege für die klimakrise zu finden
deren auswirkungen sich immer heftiger
zeigen die landwirtschaft ist von diesen
herausforderungen ganz besonders
betroffen und unsere landwirten und
landwirte spüren dass jeden tag
steigende kosten bei mineraldüngern und
energie
dürreperioden stark wetterereignisse und
der zunehmende schwund der biodiversität
nur einige der probleme zunehmen und wir
sehen es bei der landwirtschaft ganz
besonders stark wir sind verletzlich bei
den globalen krisen
diese verlässlichkeit führt uns
eindrucksvoll vor augen welche wichtige
arbeit die landwirtinnen und landwirte
täglich für unsere gesellschaft leisten
sie sicher in unserer ernährung und
damit buchstäblich unser überleben
und dass das alles keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist sind wir
momentan
die ausbleibenden getreide lieferungen
aus der ukraine und russland die die
welternährung ernsthaft bedrohen und vor
allem im globalen süden zu schweren
hungersnöten führen können es wird
gerade aber auch deutlich dass die
landwirtschaft einen wichtigen beitrag
zur lösung dieser krisen leisten kann
dabei ist es zentral dass wir damit
aufhören kollege rief krisen
gegeneinander auszuspielen und sie damit
zu verschärfen
ich musste an dieser stelle schon sagen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union über einige ihrer anträge im
parlamentarischen verfahren habe ich
mich doch sehr gewundert jetzt ist doch
weder die zeit die mittel für die
welternährungsorganisation fao
abzusenken wie sie das gerne gemacht
hätten noch ist es zeit die förderung
von den ökolandbau zu kürzen ganz im
gegenteil
[Applaus]
starten sie mir ein zitat frau
präsidentin wir dürfen nicht eine krise
nach der anderen bewältigen sondern wir
müssen simultan vorgehen ich weiß das
ist schwierig und überfordert viele aber
wenn wir das nicht tun wenn wir warten
zum beispiel bei der lösung der ganzen
umweltprobleme dann zahlen wir später
einen viel höheren preis um eine lösung
zu erzielen ich zitiere hier nicht den
minister oder meine parteivorsitzende
klaus schwab der gründer des
weltwirtschaftsforums in davos hat es
neulich festgestellt und er hat recht
daher ist es richtig
dass wir mit diesem haushalt die weichen
stellen und die dringend notwendige
transformation der landwirtschaft
voranzutreiben um das klima zu schützen
die biodiversität zu bewahren die
qualität unserer böden zu erhalten und
damit den agrarsektor zukunftsfest zu
machen und
gleichzeitig die
ernährung und den erhalt unserer hilfe
zu sichern nur wenn wir die
herausforderungen von morgen bereits
jetzt bei der lösung der probleme von
heute mitdenken werden wir all das
gleichzeitig schaffen herzlichen dank
so weit sebastian schäffer auf den folgt
nun ulrike
schilling afd fraktion und mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister in zeiten von
krisen zeigt sich bekanntermaßen was
tatsächlich wichtig ist und wo die
größten probleme liegen erst wenn der
teller nicht mehr voll ist hört die
debatte darüber auf ob es doch noch ein
bisschen mehr bio klima und umweltschutz
oder mehr nachhaltigkeit geben darf
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch
natürlich sind alle diese punkte wichtig
auch uns als afd und den landwirten aber
man muss ein gesundes gleichgewicht
finden zwischen den zielen dem weg
dorthin und dem preis den man zu zahlen
bereit ist und auch die richtige zeit
dafür ist herr minister oeste mir auch
nach den haushaltsberatungen selig in
ihrem einzelplan viel zu wenig
innovative kraft technologieoffenheit
und entsprechende maßnahmen die dazu
führen dass wir in der zukunft noch eine
starke landwirtschaft haben werden viel
zu viel wird am ideologischen nun an der
bürokratie festgehalten das ist das
gegenteil von zukunftsgewandt das meine
ich damit der haushalt ist sehr dürftig
aufgestellt und beinhaltet fast 600
millionen euro an kürzungen gegenüber
dem vorjahr trotz der sich anbahnenden
krise dazu wird dann völlig falschen
stellen gespart und gleichzeitig geld an
vielen stellen unwirtschaftlich
ausgegeben etwa bei den 40 millionen
euro mehrausgaben für die ganzen
untergeordneten behörden ihres
ministeriums das sind die falschen
prioritäten wie es auf die fraktionen
stehen für einen starken ländlichen raum
wettbewerbsfähige bauernhöfe eine
innovative und hochtechnologische
landwirtschaft und deutschland als den
standort zur landwirtschaft wir können
nein wir müssen uns unabhängig machen in
sachen lebensmittelherstellung und wir
müssen unsere landwirtschaft in diesen
zeiten zusätzlich stärken jetzt wo die
krise da ist und sich die ersten
supermarkt regale leeren kämpfen unsere
landwirte gleich an mehreren fronten mit
den wirtschaftlichen folgen der extrem
hohen betriebsmittelkosten mit
logistischen problemen
mit personalmangel und so weiter gegen
gegenüber steht eine regierung die nur
halbherzige versprechungen abgibt was
meine ich damit im ergänzungs haushalt
stehen 120 millionen euro aber wie wo
wann und an wen die sind konkret
ausgezahlt werden steht immer noch in
den sternen die fördermittel müssen
jetzt in die höfe zu spät geliefert ist
insbesondere in der landwirtschaft fatal
diese hilfen sind übrigens nur ein
trostpreis für die landwirte wenn man
bedenkt dass beispielsweise gleichzeitig
77 millionen bei der bezuschussung in
der landwirtschaftlichen
unfallversicherung gestrichen werden das
heißt mitten in der schwersten krise
seit jahrzehnten verursachen sie noch
weitere höhe kosten für viele landwirte
das ist verrückt
und wenn es verstand vorangeht
befürchten wir dass unsere landwirte
völlig leer ausgehen werden ähnlich wie
bei den einzel staatlichen beihilfen von
bis zu 35.000 euro je betrieb bei denen
die bundesregierung nicht von dieser
möglichkeit gebrauch gemacht hat andere
eu länder schon wieder einmal zeigt sich
dass die interessen deutschlands nicht
an erster stelle die über der ampel als
auch die fraktion haben wir bereits
einer ersten lesung die kürzung der 77
millionen angetragen hat wir haben es in
der einzelberatung und auch in der
bereinigungssitzung wiederholt selbst
die unfallkasse der landwirte warnt
inzwischen dringend vor diesem schritt
und was machen sie und ihre regierung
richtig sie ignorieren dies wie auch
alle unsere anderen anträge wir haben
ihnen mit unseren anträgen aufgezeigt wo
man ohne große mühe einiges geld sparen
kann beispielsweise indem man die
enormen ausgaben reste der vorjahre erst
einmal auf braucht weniger für tagungen
und konferenzen ausgibt seit spätestens
corona müssten sie doch wissen dass
nicht jedes meeting in präsenz
stattfinden muss auch die völlig
aufgeblähten bezuschussung
beispielsweise der bundesanstalt für
landwirtschaft und ernährung kann man
reparieren
mehr geld ist nicht zwangsläufig besser
und bei den planstellen der vielen
untergeordneten das
landwirtschaftsministerium sowieso da
sah man sich schnell mal zweistellige
millionenbeträge auch bei der berühmten
verbesserung der agrarstruktur und des
küstenschutzes kurz gab zeigt sich die
völlig falsche mentalität die auswüchse
sind nämlich mehrheitlich dazu da weil
sie die auswirkungen ihrer grünen
politik auch auf der eu-ebene irgendwie
ausgleichen müssen stichwort
pflanzenschutzmittel anwendungs
verordnung das ist die pure unlogik
ihrer politik gesetze und regeln so
unpraktikabel und kostenintensiv zu
machen um sie danach mit geld
auszubügeln viel besser wäre es die
regelung so einfach zu gestalten dass
sie oft hakt es funktionieren und echt
mit geld gekauft werden müssen das würde
uns einiges an geld sparen geld das wir
beispielsweise in zukunftstechnologien
wie dem einsatz von künstlicher
intelligenz im bereich der
landwirtschaft einsetzen könnten wo es
wo wir als auf dem meer mittel beantragt
haben das wäre zukunftsgewandt meine
damen und herren ich komme zum schluss
wir haben ihnen vorschläge unterbreitet
wie korrekturen dringend notwendig wären
wo durchaus einsparpotenziale vorhanden
sind und wo wir dringend mehr ausgaben
sehen wollen solange dieser haushalt nur
den status quo verwaltet und unsere
landwirte in der schwersten krise seit
jahren sich selbst überlässt können wir
diesen haushalt nicht mittragen und
werden ihnen deswegen auf abwegen vielen
dank
ulrike spielt die cdu kündigt schon mal
die ablehnung der fdp fraktion für den
einzelplan 10 an und
auf sie folgt nun ist sicher spd
fraktion und auch mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
vorab meinen dank an meine geduldigen
mit berichterstatter der ampel sebastian
schäfer und frank schäffler danke
selbstverständlich auch an alle anderen
berichterstatter sowie an die
mitarbeitenden bei uns abgeordneten den
fraktionen im ministerium beim
rechnungshof und im ausschusssekretariat
herzlichen dank
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
letzte schwein ist abgeholt so titelte
die hna und berichtet über die
betriebsaufgabe des
schweinemastbetriebes von helmut
grandios der damit eine mehr als 300
jährige familientradition beendete nach
angaben des regionalbauernverbandes
kurhessen gab es im jahr 2010 noch 391
schweinemastbetriebe in meiner region
2020 waren es nur noch 191 das bedeutet
mehr als die hälfte allein oder schweine
mastbetriebe in meiner region hat die
existenzgrundlage verloren wenn wir als
politische entscheidungsträger keine
hilfen zur verfügung stellen und
gleichzeitig noch auflagen machen für
tierhaltung oder bewirtschaftung von
ländereien so sinnvoll das anderssein
markt tragen wir aber auch dazu bei dass
bäuerinnen und bauern bauern keine
perspektive mehr sehen und sich im stich
gelassen fühlen und diese entwicklung
war schon lange absehbar hat sich aber
durch den krieg in der ukraine wegen
ausfall von rohstoffen exorbitant
zugespitzt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unsere bäuerinnen und bauern
die wollen ihre betriebe
aufrechterhalten aber
vorrangig wollen sie auch gar nicht
unterstützt werden durch
finanzhilfen sondern sie wollen
planungssicherheit wenn sie investieren
wer von ihnen wäre bereit in ein heim
für sich selbst zu investieren mit der
ungewissheit das vor auslaufen einer
finanzierung wegen neuer vorschriften
weitere investitionen getätigt und
wieder finanziert werden müssten ich
behaupte keiner von uns würde das tun
aber von unseren bäuerinnen und bauern
erwarten wir dass und das müssen wir
endlich ändern um wieder
zukunftsperspektiven zu schaffen
das ministerium wird in diesem jahr ein
konzept zur finanzierung des umbaus der
tierhaltung vorstellen und ich erwarte
daher dass gerade dieser faktor
planungssicherheit dann auch einen
besonderen rang eingeräumt bekommt der
haushalt 2022 der einzelplan 10 umfasst
rund 570 millionen euro weniger als 2021
das wurde schon vielfach kritisiert
josef rief wir haben das auch beide
schon mehrfach ausgetauscht aber ich
finde die kritik
ist nicht gerechtfertigt denn allein
über 800 millionen aus dem etat des
letzten jahres sind überhaupt nicht
abgeflossen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die titel mit den ausgabe
resten die also letztes jahr übrig
geblieben sind haben wir dann als ampel
haushälter zur gegenfinanzierung genutzt
und zwar werden wir unter anderem bei
den see fischern die auch extreme
betriebskosten haben durch die teuren
diesel preise bei den betriebskosten
entlassen und wir werden anreize
schaffen zum umrüsten auf
emissionsärmere antriebe
auch die tierheime werden
noch einmal unterstützen
im ausschuss hat es der kollege schon
angesprochen das war nicht so ganz
leicht zu ein aber wir haben es doch
geschafft und zwar die tierheime die für
die impfungen und quarantänemaßnahmen
ukrainischer tiere aufkommen müssten die
entlasten wir und für tierarzneimittel
für die ukraine stellen wir ebenfalls
auch nochmal fünf millionen euro zur
verfügung bei uns da diese hilferufe
entsprechend erreicht haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unser
wald ist nicht das problem sondern die
lösung für unser ziel nämlich mit
nachwachsenden rohstoffen zu bauen und
energie zu erzeugen und das müssen wir
nutzen und auch die waldbesitzer dabei
unterstützen unsere wälder zu erhalten
zum einen als erholungsort für uns
selbst aber wälder sind eben nicht nur
erholungsorte für uns sondern sie sind
ob energielieferanten und co2 speicher
es lohnt sich daher dass in diesem
bundeshaushalt nicht im einzelplan
bundeshaushalt im 160 200 millionen euro
zusätzlich eingestellt sind für die
honorierung der ökosystemleistungen des
waldes
wir haben 1 ampel angefangen ausgabe
resten die rote karte zu zeigen denn das
ist vom bundesrechnungshof schon über
viele jahre kritisiert worden dass
gerade dieses ministerium da vorreiter
war
ausgabereste zurückzubehalten und wir
stellen die ampel auf grün für
bedarfsgerechte haushaltstiteln in
diesem haushalt stehen auch noch einige
titel auf gelb in der warteschleife mit
sperrvermerken und warten auf
freischaltungen bei vorlage von
konzepten für die umsetzung das ist klug
und umsichtig ich bitte daher um ihre
zustimmung und lade sie außerdem am 12
juni nach schöneberg zum milch stark ein
das habe ich versprochen
gut weitere details zu diesem milchtag
müssen wohl nachgeliefert werden das war
esther der spd fraktion hat sich hier
auch nochmal bei den anderen
berichterstattern bedankt für diesen
einzelplan in eppendorf spricht jetzt
für die linksfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen schon am 24
april bei der einbringung des haushaltes
habe ich die kürzung im einzelplan 10
zum vorjahr scharf kritisiert nichts
aber auch nichts grundsätzliches hat
sich seither bewegt 71 milliarden euro
sind immer noch 7,1 milliarden minimale
1,43 prozent des gesamthaushaltes stehen
für die transformation der
landwirtschaft die sicherung der
ernährung den verbraucherschutz die
ländlichen räume die fischerei und die
fonds zur verfügung zu wenig meine damen
und herren
die ankommen ziel ist es zu agrarwende
heiße luft
zwischen den herausforderungen in der
agrarpolitik und den dürftigen mitteln
in diesem haushalt gibt es ein krasses
missverhältnis es ist seit monaten nicht
einmal der versuch unternommen worden
die vollmundigen erklärungen der
regierung über die bevorstehende
zusammenarbeit zwischen landwirtschafts
und umweltministeriums mit planungen
oder oder gar taten zu versehen wo ist
hier greenteam
irgendetwas in richtung sozialer
ökologischer umbau der gesellschaft
fehlanzeige wirksame maßnahmen gegen
ernährung spekulationen und
preistreiberei fehlanzeige begrenzung
der marktmacht von lebensmittelkonzernen
die dringend notwendig wären um die
landwirtinnen und landwirte genauso wie
die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher zu
entlasten
auch fehlanzeige
das alles regeln sie in diesem haushalt
nicht liebe kollegen nur kollegen weder
die schon sichtbaren folgen des
klimawandels noch die absehbaren
kriegsfolgen haben außer
lippenbekenntnisse ein sichtbares
handelns bewusst seien bisher nicht
erkennen lassen sie haben keine
maßnahmenkatalog vorgelegt die probleme
an der wurzel packt da bewilligt die eu
kommission der bundesregierung 60
millionen euro anpassungs hilfe für
erzeuger auf dem agrarsektor die
regierung legt noch einmal 160 millionen
euro dazu das klingt sehr gut nur wo
finden wir diese summe im einzelplan 60
des finanzministeriums und sie herr
minister sind dann bittsteller was soll
das und dann ist noch nicht immer klar
erste geld bekommen soll wie viel und
vor allem wann endlich einmal zahlungen
würden die strukturdefizite in der
landwirtschaft nicht beheben ich sage es
bedarf einer gezielten unterstützung für
die landwirtschaft beim umbau und bei
den strukturanpassung ohne diese werden
viele landwirte aufgeben müssen und das
darf nicht sein das gleiche wird
für die fischerei hilfen beihilfe
strukturmaßnahmen für die seefischerei
werden neu eingerichtet sind angesetzt
wir haben das rad gehört angekündigt
worden insgesamt 11,5 millionen euro und
auch hier muss die frage erlaubt sein wo
das geld hingeht und wie es eingesetzt
wird und wann es kommt
antworten darauf wartet die
fischereiwirtschaft auch in meinem
bundesland mecklenburg vorpommern schon
seit langem mit weiterem zögere zögern
der regierung wird die fischerei
insbesondere die küstenfischerei bald
ein style für das heimatmuseum und bei
aller berechtigter kritik für den
raubbau unter anderem raubbau und an der
überfischung das kann doch nicht das
ziel sein meine damen und herren nun
sprechen wir im einzelplan 10 ja auch
über ernährung und zwar über gesunde
ernährung seit jahren gibt es in
deutschland
eine nachgewiesene ernährungs armut
gerade aktuell befördert die
preistreiberei der konzerne im handel
diese armut weiter
laut ard recherche feld ist 38 prozent
der menschen in deutschland zunehmend
schwerer die dinge des täglichen lebens
bezahlen zu können armut bedingte fehl
und mangelernährung und sogar hunger in
einer gesellschaft die so wohlhabend ist
wie deutschland das ist für mich und
meine fraktion inakzeptabel
vor vier monaten habe ich gesagt im bio
markt bleibt der chor player weil das
geld nicht reicht nun trifft es auch für
den supermarkt zu
12,5 millionen menschen in deutschland
leben unter der armutsgefährdungsgrenze
und schon vor der derzeitigen preis
explosion bei lebensmittel war für diese
menschen frisches obst und gemüse ein
luxus und das ist eine schande für
dieses reiche land
das eine gesunde ernährung gerade für
die jugend am besten über öffentliche
angebote wie die schulverpflegung
erreicht werden kann besagt schon 2020
eine studie des wissenschaftlichen
beirates für agrarpolitik ernährung und
gesundheitlichen verbraucherschutz im
bmf die zentrale empfehlung des
berichtes lautet eine beitragsfreie
qualitativ hochwertige kita und
schulverpflegung schrittweise in ganz
deutschland zu etablieren
das ist auch aus meiner sicht eine der
wichtigsten drängten und nicht zu sechs
auch wirksamste maßnahme um eine gesunde
ernährung zu erreichen leider ist
deutschland davon weit entfernt
dass dies möglich sein kann zeigt
finnland dort gibt es sie die
kostenfreie hochwertige nachhaltige
verpflegung für alle kinder und
jugendlichen in schulen und
kindertageseinrichtungen man muss es nur
wollen
eine gezielte unterstützung des bundes
für die kommunen wäre hier notwendig und
möglich wir haben dies beantragt aber
eine finanzierung in diesem haushalt
wurde abgelehnt sie können sicher sein
dass die linke dafür solange mittel im
haushalt fordern wird bis sie das
endlich aufgreifen für mich und meine
fraktion ist dieser haushalt alles in
allem ein armutszeugnis agrar und
ernährungspolitik für die zukunft sieht
anders aus kindern
das wort hat der kollege frank schäffler
für die fdp frau zu
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen
wenn wir heute über den einzelplan 10
debattieren dann geht es um einen ganzen
berufsstand und die landwirte und für
uns freien demokraten sind landwirte
unternehmer sie erzeugen lebensmittel
und mit diesen lebensmitteln mit diesen
erträgen die sie erzielen wollen sie
gewinne erwirtschaften dafür braucht es
die notwendigen weichenstellungen
und zu diesen weichenstellungen gehört
das dasein moratorium an auflagen und
immer neuen vorschriften bedarf
wir haben im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart dass planungs und
investitionssicherheit
existieren soll und genau darum geht es
da wo die folgen für den staat
oder für die für die unternehmer
besonders existenziell sind da wollen
wir helfen und deshalb haben wir im
haushalts in den haushaltsberatungen
auch zehn millionen für die fischerei
zur verfügung gestellt
und wir haben bei der umrüstung beim
flottenumbau für küsten- und
krabbenfischerei ebenfalls mittel zur
verfügung gestellt damit moderner
antriebstechniken dort auch einzug
halten auch das ist teil unseres
koalitionsvertrages gewesen
aber
es braucht künftig mehr es braucht ein
paradigmenwechsel der kanzler hat mich
ohne grund von zeitenwende gesprochen
und die zeitenwende die wir auch in der
landwirtschaft haben durch den
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine muss auch
konsequenzen für unsere
landwirtschaftspolitik in deutschland
haben und dann ist natürlich wohl fall
wenn jetzt die union hier
mängel darstellt die sie selbst 16 jahre
verursacht hat es war ja letztendlich
die union die die bauern milliarden zur
verfügung gestellt hat brosamen verteilt
hat letztendlich zu kratie erzeugt hat
keine planungssicherheit geschaffen hat
gängelung an jeder ecke erzeugt hat das
war die union dass das ergebnis von 16
jahren union in der
landwirtschaftspolitik und das und das
gibt es auch schwarz auf weiß der
unabhängige normenkontrollrat hat den
berichtsjahr
2021 und 2020 dargestellt dass damals
300 millionen euro an belastungen auf
die landwirtschaft durch die gesetze der
damaligen bundesregierung hinzu gekommen
sind das aktionsprogramm zum
insektenschutz mit 150 millionen
beispielsweise seit 2016 war es noch
gravierender da hat die landwirtschaft
bürokratische lasten von über 800
millionen auf sich zukommen lassen die
verschärfung der düngeverordnung war
beispielsweise einer der wesentlichen
punkt punkte also sie können sich nicht
hinstellen dass sie die retter der
ländlichen strukturen und der
landwirtschaft sind sondern sie haben
das elend im wesentlichen mit verursacht
aber auch aber auch die ampel koalition
muss sich diesen neuen
realitäten stellen ich glaube wir müssen
darüber diskutieren ob die
flächenstilllegungen in der
landwirtschaft in deutschland ob das
tatsächlich in diese zeit passt
alle ebenen starten
alle eu-staaten
haben die drei prozentige reduzierung
der flächen
aufgehoben ausgesetzt deutschland hat
dagegen von drei
prozent eine 4 punkt gemacht also es
ausgeweitet und deshalb glaube ich
sollten wir gut daran tun das zu
überdenken 4% flächenstilllegung und
deutschland entspricht 4 millionen
hektar produktionsfläche das ist das
dass es das was der importbedarf an
weizen von ägypten äthiopien marokko
südafrika und tunesien ausmacht also die
länder die sehr wahrscheinlich besonders
unter der hungerkatastrophe die uns auf
uns zukommt letztendlich leiden werden
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass auch in der
düngemittel politik letztendlich mehr
realismus einkehrt wir müssen die
produktionskapazitäten
steigern um die welternährung in den
griff zu bekommen und das sind
letztendlich eine reduktion der
produktionskapazitäten in europa und in
deutschland falsch
und letztendlich glaube ich müssen wir
dafür sorgen dass wir für mehr welt
handlung mehr freien handel sorgen
letztendlich hat die eu kommission nach
wie vor man muss sich das vorstellen hat
die eu kommission in der europäische
union nach wie vor zölle von über 50
prozent von über 50 prozent auf
milcherzeugnisse
getreide und zucker obwohl gleichzeitig
eine ernährungskrise auf dieser welt
droht warum sorgen wir nicht dafür dass
diese zölle einseitig abgebaut werden
damit die preise auch sinken können auch
in europa sinken können in diesem
bereich
und gleichzeitig ist es notwendig dass
wir den welthandel auch bilateral wieder
in gang setzen wir müssen endlich das
welthandelsabkommen ca das bilaterale
handelsabkommen zeta im deutschen
bundestag ratifizieren das der erste
schritt
von der zweite schritt ist dass wir die
reform der welthandelsorganisation
endlich voranbringen auch da hat die
vorgängerregierung nicht geliefert und
auch da können wir als regierung voran
gehen letztendlich geht es um bezahlt
da kommen wir zum schluss letztendlich
gehe es und bezahlbare lebensmittel das
ist nicht nur eine frage der geldpolitik
sondern das auch eine frage der
handelspolitik und da muss diese
regierung ansetzen vielen dank
die forderung von frank schäffler auf
ihn antworten kann albrecht stegemann
sprecher für ernährung und
landwirtschaft der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
2022 solle so erleben wir es alle wohl
ist das jahr der großen schlagzeilen und
das jahr der großen veränderung vor
allem mit solche mit denen wohl keiner
gerechnet hatte zeitenwende in fast
allen lebensbereichen auch im bereich
der lebensmittel erzeugung verarbeitung
aber auch im vertrieb so titelt der
fokus heute morgen menschen können sich
weniger leisten stärkste umsatzeinbruch
aller zeiten im lebensmittelhandel und
tatsächlich das war absehbar nachdem in
den letzten jahren das wohnen in den
eigenen vier wänden immer teurer
geworden ist erleben wir nun dass sich
die lebensmittelpreise teilweise
exorbitant entwickeln über die
vielfältigen ursachen haben wir auch
hier im bundestag viel und lange geredet
wenn wir aber heute hier über den
bundeshaushalt sprechen dann will ich an
dieser stelle aber auch über die
haushaltslage der menschen in unserem
land reden inflation war lange nicht
mehr als ein technischer begriff das
geld verliert seinen wert das lernt
jedes kind in der schule aktuell müssen
wir aber feststellen inflation ist viel
mehr als das es ist das unsozialste was
einem land passieren kann
denn gerade die einkommensschwachen sind
am schlimmsten betroffen denn die
lebensbereiche in denen wir die höchsten
teuerungsraten haben wohnen heizen
mobilität und eben vor allem ernährung
sind die wirtschaftlich schwächeren
überproportional betroffen wer als
durchschnittsverdiener vor etwa einem
jahr noch nach abzug seines nettolohns
von miete auto und lebensmitteln noch ca
200 euro übrig hatte schaut jetzt besten
das in ein leeres portemonnaie das ist
leider die bittere realität
zeiten von inflation sind auch zeiten
von geringem angebot wir sehen jeden tag
wie knapp zum beispiel weizen
sonnenblumenöl und düngemittel sind da
begrenzte ressourcen ein teil des
problems sind müssen wir genau hier
ansetzen in jedem anderen
wirtschaftsbereich ist es
selbstverständlich dass der effiziente
einsatz von vorhandenen ressourcen ein
mehr an nachhaltigkeit bedeutet nur in
der landwirtschaft gibt es das
weitverbreitete dogma dass
nachhaltigkeit nur mit extensivierung zu
erreichen ist und darüber müssen wir
unbedingt reden und hier müssen wir zu
einem umdenken kommen herr minister
wir müssen den preisauftrieb und den
damit eng verbunden dem hunger in der
welt etwas entgegensetzen deshalb
brauchen wir auch eine offene diskussion
darüber wie wir unsere
nachhaltigkeitsziele effizient erreichen
können flächenstilllegung zulassungs
behinderung neuer umweltverträglicher
pflanzenschutzmittel oder das verteufeln
neuer züchtung technologien gehören in
die mottenkiste und sind gewiss nicht
teil einer zukunftsorientierten
landwirtschaft
und wenn ich mir dann den haushalt des
br mails anschaue habe ich wirklich
nicht den eindruck dass sie übt dort
überhaupt ein problembewusstsein
vorhanden ist - 156 millionen euro plant
die ampel gegenüber den vorschlägen der
cdu 0 euro zusätzliche mittel im
ergänzungs haushalt und auch die
bereinigungssitzung
geht auch mit - 244.000 euro aus den
verhandlungen herr minister ihr aus halt
geht aus jeder verhandlungsrunde kleiner
raus wie er reingegangen ist ich glaube
da haben sie offenkundig ein problem
aber viel schlimmer als die tatsache
als diese tatsache wie sie eben mit dem
haushalt umgehend ist die tatsache wie
sie eben ob das geld ausgehen den
landwirtschaftlichen betrieben streichen
sie die zuschüsse für die
landwirtschaftliche unfallversicherung
zusammen die hilfen für die deutsche
fischerei betriebe fließen in dieser
ganz dramatischen zeit einfach viel zu
spät andere länder waren viel früher als
die bundesrepublik deutschland aber auch
die kürzung von vier millionen euro im
investitions und zukunftsprogramm
landwirtschaft sendet das völlig falsche
signal an die landwirte dabei hat die
union dabei haben wir doch sehr gute
vorschläge gemacht wir wollten die
landwirte um rund 200 millionen euro
entlasten zusätzlich zu den geldern aus
dem eu krisen paket wollen wir bei den
agrar diesel kosten eine entlassung es
wird ja gerade auch noch mal angedeutet
von 120 millionen euro ins spiel bringen
das hätte die betriebe bei denen dieser
kosten um zehn cent je liter entlastet
das war oder ist höchstwahrscheinlich
mit ihnen nicht zu machen aber auch die
geplante absenkung des bundeszuschusses
zur landwirtschaftlichen
unfallversicherung
das haben sie jetzt einfach
zurückgedreht wir fordern wir können
damit überhaupt nicht leben wir wollen
im gegenteil wieder auf das alte niveau
zurück wir wollen die 107 oder die 77
millionen wieder in diesen bereich
investieren um landwirtschaftliche
familienbetriebe zu entlassen
ganz wichtig dass unsere landwirte
dürfen nicht zur spardose der ampel
koalition werden und sie sind dabei
genau das zu implementieren
unsere heimischen landwirte stehen vor
schicksalsjahr auch als gesellschaft
brauchen wir jetzt maßnahmen die die
ernährungssicherheit mit artenvielfalt
und klimaschutz zusammenführen wir
brauchen borchert jetzt bevor es zu spät
ist ohne frisches geld wird das nicht
funktionieren aber gestern hat ja leider
die fdp hier den ersten sargnagel
gesetzt das hat mich sehr mit trauer
erfüllt von der ampel gibt es aber bis
heute nicht einen neuen hilfreichen
impuls im bereich der ernährungs und
landwirtschafts politik keine antwort
auf die aktuelle rekord inflation bei
den lebensmittel keine erkennbaren
schritte für investitionen in eine
moderne landwirtschaft der zweite
entwurf zum haushaltsgesetz 2022 ist
eine verschlechterung und wird den
aktuellen herausforderungen nicht
gerecht deswegen lehnen wir dem
vorschlag ab und gehen haushalt vielen
dank für ihren
und nun spricht auch der angesprochene
minister cem özdemir
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister jetzt zu
seinem etat einzelplan ziehen
da für ernährung und landwirtschaft
demonstrieren
denn sie lieben kollegen überlegen der
politikwissenschaftler peter graf
kielmansegg
demokratien mal einen eklatanten zukunft
schwäche attestiert nun werden auch
festgestellt dass sie die besten chancen
habe einen fairen ausgleich zwischen
gegenwart und zukunft zu schaffen wenn
sie sich als lernfähig erweisen diese
lernfähigkeit brauchen wir gerade auch
im bereich der agrarpolitik die liste
der herausforderungen ist lang sie
kennen sie hilfe sterben dürren
überschwemmungen als zeichen der
klimakrise artensterben übernutzung von
böden und tieren und schließlich der
zusätzliche kosten druck infolge des
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
ukraine
das sieht okay sagen beim angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine des passes stetig jedes
vorurteil über sie meine
dass wir seine unfähigkeit durch sein
schweigen vermuten lässt verstehe ich
aber man muss es durchs reden nicht auch
noch unter beweis stellen
es ist es ist offenkundig dass wir
veränderungen brauchen gerade weil
landwirtschaft vor von existenzieller
bedeutung für uns alle ist dabei braucht
es die bereitschaft zum kompromiss und
natürlich auch pragmatische lösungen
dieser haushalt ist der für ein gutes
beispiel wir verbinden auf der einen
seite planungssicherheit in der agro
sozialen sicherung mit neuen ideen im
ökolandbau wir investieren denn
forschung in die entwicklung in die
digitalisierung übrigens unglaublich
spannende chancen eröffnet ich möchte
ihn an der stelle liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ausdrücklich danken dass sie
die 60 millionen aus der eu krisen
reserve 120 millionen erhöht haben wir
wollen diese 180 millionen zielgerichtet
schnell und vor allem unbürokratisch auf
unsere hilfe bringen wir wollen
wir wollen die übermäßig von steigenden
energiepreisen betroffenen
gartenbaubetriebe den obst- und weinbau
sowie die tierhaltungsbetriebe gezielt
entlassen das gilt übrigens auch für die
fischerei für die sie in der
bereinigungssitzung zehn millionen euro
ermöglicht haben eine dringend
notwendige unterstützung auch dafür
danke ich
meine damen meine herren die sich
zurzeit über lagen den krisen zeigen
aber auch wie dringend und wie
notwendigkeit die transformation unserer
landwirtschaft ist unsere politik muss
ernährungssicherung und sie muss
gleichzeitig dem erhalt der höhe
verdient sie muss zugleich auch klima
böden arten schützen um sie überhaupt
noch nutzen zu können all diese aspekte
bedingen sich gegenseitig wir können das
eine nicht ohne das andere haben und an
der stelle dachte ich ehrlich gesagt
beim zuhören liebe kollegen das richtet
sich vor allem an sie von der union dass
wir da eigentlich schon mal weiter waren
im deutschen bundestag was den konsens
angeht analyse der krise über die wege
aus der krise können wir uns gerne
streiten das ist normal in der
demokratie ist auch die aufgabe der
opposition aber die analyse der krise
das für dein deutschland zumindest einig
sind wenn sie das jetzt aufkündigen was
klima krise angeht das artensterben
angeht das finde ich sehr bedauerlich
weil das wird das arbeiten in dieser
republik künftig nicht leichter macht
sie und ich und wir alle stehen
gemeinsam in der verantwortung dass wir
dem auch tatsächlich gerecht werden denn
nur so schaffen wir einen fairen
ausgleich zwischen der gegenwart und der
zukunft auch der nächste haushalt wird
dafür sicherlich ein gradmesser sein
vielen dank
der bundesminister für ernährung und
landwirtschaft im alte mir hat hier auch
nochmal die opposition direkt
angesprochen ohne auf ihn direkt
antworten wird peter felser auf die
fraktion und mitglied des ausschusses
für ernährung und landwirtschaft
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister liebe kollegen
liebe landwirt der liebe gäste herr
minister ich hätte schon erwartet dass
sie länger als vier minuten reden oder
sie vor allem inhaltlich zur sache reden
hier gibt es wirklich wichtige dinge
heute
und auch die kollegen von der fdp das
kann doch nicht wahr sein bis sie hier
als heuchler sich hinstellen und sagen
die zwangs brache darf und sein tier
reagiert und zurzeit wenn die zwangs
brachte kommt dann habt ihr sie mit
verschuldet wie kollegen
[Applaus]
ja es gibt tatsächlich punkte im
einzelnen am 10 die wir auch
unterstützen wenn wir an die
digitalisierung denken wenn es um die
zukunft unserer landwirtschaftlichen
betriebe geht hier müssen wir sogar mehr
leisten lassen sie mich zwei beispielen
erstens datenhoheit wie im gehirn denn
in zukunft all die daten die jetzt schon
gesammelt werden auf den traktoren beim
herdenmanagement bei den anschlag datei
lassen sie uns diese daten intelligent
verknüpfen bevor es die ganz großen
player machen das wäre ein ansatz und
eine hilfe wenn es um die
digitalisierung geht liebe kollegen
zweites beispiel wenn wir die
lieferketten mit hilfe von block chain
technik intelligenter verknüpfen dann
schaffen wir nicht nur größeren mehrwert
für die produzenten dann werden wir auch
die lebensmittelverschwendung eindämmen
können da sollten wir investieren und
wir meinen da müssen wir auch mehr
investieren
[Applaus]
ich möchte aber auch die gelegenheit
nutzen heute die aktuellen hilfen für
unsere landwirte anzusprechen wenn wir
uns die einzelnen staatlichen beihilfen
ansehen dann kann von hilfe da keine
rede mehr sein unser der deutschen
betriebe ging komplett leer aus und das
kann doch in dieser lage in dieser
schwierigen situation nicht das signal
an unsere bauern seien manche können
sich manche bauern können sich den anbau
schon gar nicht mehr leisten weil die
kosten für die betriebsmittel explodiert
sind wir haben sie schon gehört die eu
kommission hat das ja ausdrücklich
genehmigt um die hohen kosten für die
betriebsmittel abzufedern um überhaupt
die existenz gefährdeten betriebe am
leben zu erhalten um die
ernährungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
dafür könnten wir bis zu 35.000 euro pro
betrieb ausgeben und fast alle
europäischen nachbarn herr minister fast
alle nachbarn nutzen diese möglichkeit
der einzigen staatlichen beihilfen außer
deutschland wertschätzung herr minister
wertschätzung für die bauern das sieht
anders aus
[Applaus]
lassen sie mich bei dieser gelegenheit
auch auf die agrarsubventionen zu
sprechen kommen hier wollen sie ja bei
den waldbesitzern beim umbau zu klima
stabilen bildern in der ähnliche
richtung gehen aber schauen wir uns mal
an wer sind eigentlich die größten
leistungsempfänger und man lese und
staune die größten nutznießer von
subventionen von steuergeldern waren im
vergangenen jahr wieder einmal nicht
unsere landwirt sondern zum beispiel das
landesamt für umwelt in brandenburg mit
14,3 millionen euro oder das sächsische
staatsministerium für energie
klimaschutz umwelt und landwirtschaft
mit
7,7 millionen euro so waren diese
unterstützungs hilfen nie gedacht und
nicht angelegt gewesen sie sollten
einzig und alleine für unsere bauern
ausgegeben werden das ist sonst
etikettenschwindel liebe freunde
das wort zeitenwende hat hochkonjunktur
und allein in dieser haushaltswoche
werden gigantische summen aufgerufen für
diese wende morgen soll sogar das
grundgesetz geändert werden aber ich
frage mich ein minister ist es der nicht
mindestens genauso wichtig diese
milliarden für panzer diese
milliardeninvestitionen für flugzeuge
für unsere bundeswehr ist es dann nicht
vielleicht sogar wichtiger endlich in
eine agrarwende zu investieren die
diesen namen auch verdient wir hätten
uns gewünscht und wir hätten das auch
gerne in diesem haushalt gesehen dass
sie neben ihren ganzen klimazielen neben
ihren öko ziel dass sie neben ihren
ideologischen planungen einfach eine
einzige kennzahl dahinter schreiben eine
kernzeit alles satt über die zukunft und
die wertschätzung unserer landwirtschaft
haben sie doch einmal den mut sich daran
zu messen wie viele landwirtschaftliche
betriebe pro jahr nicht aufgeben wie
viele überleben werden in diesem jahr in
den nächsten jahren das ist doch für
unser land jetzt ganz entscheidend in
der pandemie haben wir die
landwirtschaft als systemrelevant
eingestuft absolut richtig jetzt in
kriegszeiten in zeiten steigender
inflation haben wir erkannt dass unsere
landwirtschaft überlebenswichtig ist
absolut richtig in der letzten
aussprache haben sie selbst der minister
das höfesterben unter der merkel
regierung kritisiert machen sie doch
bitte endlich das höfesterben zu der
kennzahl die uns allen weiterhilft
ich glaube es ist langsam an der zeit
herr minister dass sie mal ihre alten
sprechzettel wettlesen man sie endlich
eine agrarpolitik die sich am erfolg
messen lassen kann für die zukunft
unserer landkarte für die
ernährungssicherheit in unserer heimat
für eine wertschätzung unserer
lebensmittel vielen dank
peter felser war das für die fdp
fraktion
hat dem minister zu dazu die alten
zettel wegzulegen auch das haben wir in
dieser haushaltsdebatte schon mal gehört
allerdings da in richtung bundeskanzler
anbetracht das ziel dass die kolleginnen
und kollegen im haus damit gemeint haben
nicht mehr zu verwenden es kein guter
parlamentarischer ausdruck wenn das
nächste mal vorkommt da teile ich ein
ordnungsruf vielen dank
hier gab es noch mal einen hinweis von
yvonne mag was das hier die abgeordneten
nicht als heuchler beschimpft werden
und kollegen will an die worte des
bundesministers anschließen denn das was
wir in der landwirtschaftspolitik ja in
den letzten jahren erleben ist eine sehr
sehr starke polarisierung und die frage
ob demokratie in der lage ist
tatsächlich
zukunftsfähigkeit herzustellen das ist
schon zentral und deswegen sage ich ganz
bewusst an die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer die heute diese debatte sehen
ich habe in den letzten jahren auch in
der großen koalition durchaus positive
dinge erlebt und ich war und bin nach
wie vor ganz stolz aber ich bin wirklich
erschrocken wie schnell
errungenschaften in frage gestellt
werden gerade heute und gestern die
frage zb die sie alle mit aus guten
gründen entschieden haben sollen
atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden ja
oder nein wie halten wir es mit
biologischer vielfalt
klimaschutz und landwirtschaft sie
stellen diese grundsätze gegeneinander
aufgrund einer krise die gehirn aber
miteinander gedacht liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und wenn ich hin und wenn sie jetzt
beispielsweise die hunger problematik
ansprechen und sagen man müsste mal da
ein bisschen auch das und das verzichten
hier dann verkennen sie dass ein großer
grund für hunger in dieser welt die
klimakrise ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
dann verkennen sie dass ein großer grund
dass der wegfall der biologischen
vielfalt ist liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen tun sie doch nicht so als ob
diese probleme einfach so beiseite
gewischt werden könnten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und ich sage
ihnen auch und ich sage ihnen auch es
zieht dazu es ist jetzt die aufgabe
tatsächlich das weiter zu denken was in
den letzten jahren passiert worden es
haben sich nämlich jenseits des
parlaments die unterschiedlichen gruppen
zusammengetan wir haben mit der
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft
eine blaupause für das was wir zu tun
haben diese zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft setzte sich zusammen aus
dem bauernverband aus umweltverbänden
aus gruppen die ganz unterschiedlich die
dinge miteinander gedacht haben und das
ist die blaupause daraus wird was und
nicht gehen dann das gegeneinander
ausspielt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich sage ihnen auch er stegemann
vielen dank für diese stichwort und
jetzt müssen sie ganz tapfer sein denn
borchert ist tatsächlich ein sehr sehr
gutes stichwort borchert hat etwas
gemacht und die botschaft kommission wo
wir versöhnen tierhaltung und
planungssicherheit für landwirtinnen und
landwirte was wir nicht geschafft haben
leider in dieser großen koalition auch
aufgrund der cdu
landwirtschaftsministerin ist gewesen
zum beispiel zu einer verbindlichen
kennzeichnung zu kommen weil sie gesagt
hat es ist schlichtweg nicht möglich und
das verspreche ich ihnen jetzt herrscht
hegemann ist gefährlich hier das zu
machen weil sie mich vielleicht daran
messen können aber ich bin inzwischen
ganz sicher nach der vertrauensvollen
zusammenarbeit mit grünen und fdp dass
wir dieses diese große aufgabe in diesem
jahr noch lösen borchert wird umgesetzt
werden liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wenn sie herr stegemann jetzt die
fdp kritisieren dann sage ich warten sie
mal ab das was ich bei ihnen erlebt habe
genau in diesen fragen der
zukunftsfähigkeit war blockade ich
erlebe die fdp ich erlebe die grünen im
moment so dass wir ein ziel haben aber
sie haben recht die frage der
finanzierung ist im moment tatsächlich
noch strittig aber ich sage ganz bewusst
auch herr kollege stegemann hier gehört
zum planungssicherheit dazu wenn wir den
landwirten einen hohen standard zumuten
wollen und das wollen wir weil wir wohl
mit der zukunftsfähigkeit von landwirten
verbinden wollen dann heißt es auch die
finanzierungsfrage zu klären denn wir
können landwirte nicht dort alleine
lassen deswegen ist diese
haushaltsberatung
deswegen ist diese haushaltsberatung die
blaupause für das was wir im nächsten
jahr garantiert brauchen nämlich auch
mehr mittel um tierschutz und zukunft
der landwirtschaft in deutschland
tatsächlich zu sichern das ist unsere
aufgabe ich bin mir sicher in dieser
ampel koalition werden wir das schaffen
die wir kolleginnen und kollegen
und da bin ich zum schluss dann bei
demokratie
nichts ist selbstverständlich alles das
was wir hier entscheiden ist durchaus
auch ganz schnell wieder
vielleicht auch veränderbar wir reden
jetzt aber über einen bereich wo
viele menschen richtig viel geld in die
hand nehmen müssen um zum beispiel neue
stelle zu bauen und deswegen hoffe ich
dass sie ihre blockadehaltung der
letzten jahre bei diesem thema beenden
und mit uns zusammen sie bitte zum
schluss an einem an einem modell
arbeiten was tatsächlich
zukunftsfähigkeit in deutschland
darstellt ist sie jedenfalls dazu
herzlich ein vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und
hier ist in mersch hat hier unter
anderem die brüchert kommission erwähnt
eine kommission unter den ehemaligen
bundesminister für ernährung
landwirtschaft und forsten
borchert die im vergangenen jahr
vorschläge für den umbau von
nutztierhaltung
eingereicht
hatten ihre kolleginnen und kollegen in
der letzte woche hat bei uns im
münsterland an land wird seine reifen
erdbeeren einfach abgemäht und
untergepflügt hier soll demnächst in der
nächsten woche schon meist wachsen sagte
er damit der acker in diesem jahr noch
geld bringt für 500 gramm schale
erdbeeren würde er vom einzelhandel nur
1 euro und 1 cent bekommen damit zahle
er drauf der handel kauft aktuell
geliefert während in spanien aber bei
den hohen energie sprit dünger und
lohnkosten können deutschlands
erdbeerbauern mit den spanischen einfach
nicht konkurrieren
immer wieder sehen die lebensmittel die
vernichtet werden die zu klein zu krumm
nicht abzusetzen sind das ist in
normalen zeiten schon schlimm aber in
zeiten von hungerkrisen völlig irre das
system unserer lebensmittelproduktion
ist völlig absurd und wie verzweifelt
müssen beuren bauern seien um so zu
handeln viele geben einfach leise auf
aktuell verlieren wir vorher nicht sich
betriebe und anbauflächen und die selbst
versorgungsquote sinkt bedrohlich auf
unter 21 prozent das höfesterben
schreitet derzeit überall massiv voran
dabei sind gerade die kleineren
strukturen von fundamentaler bedeutung
für unsere dörfer unsere unabhängigkeit
und unsere artenvielfalt aber jahrzehnte
lang hat die politik gerade die cdu csu
immer wieder nur das wachstum getrimmt
der landwirtschaft auf kosten von natur
dazu kam die flächen förderung als gab
er gab als wachstumsbeschleuniger und
gerade der obstbau der mit kleinen
flächen braucht nur ist dabei der
größere familie wird verlierer gut ist
dass die krisenhilfe der jetzt mit 120
millionen aufgestockt wurde damit können
jetzt die betroffenen betriebe schnell
unterstützt werden aber
landwirtschaftspolitik muss nicht die
hausaufgaben von sozialpolitik oder
faire steuerpolitik übernehmen
landwirtschaft politik ist nicht dafür
zuständig gesunde regionale lebensmittel
zu billigstpreisen zu produzieren
sondern politik muss die verbraucher in
die lage versetzen auch gesunde
nachhaltige lebensmittel einkaufen zu
können und genau dahin hat die
bundesregierung genau richtig indem sie
mit den langfristigen und kurzfristigen
maßnahmen der entlastungspaket die
einkommen entlastet und auch den zwölf
euro mindestlohn einführt energiepreis
pauschale kinderbonus erhöhung des
grundfreibetrages
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag erhöhung und
und und ich könnte noch vieles aufsehen
und richtig wäre jetzt auch die
reduktion der mehrwertsteuer wie es ist
er mir vorgeschlagen hatte und viele
andere sozialverbände ja auch
aber für unsere versorgungssicherheit
und die unsere enkel ist jetzt die
soziale ökologische transformation der
landwirtschaft wichtiger denn je es ist
jetzt unsere aufgabe diesen seit
jahrzehnten kann ich mich falsche
richtung gesteuerten tanker wieder auf
den richtigen kurs zu bringen und erste
weichen sind in diesem haushalt gestellt
eine milliarde umbau auf der tierhaltung
aufstockung bundesprogramm ökolandbau
und und kommen sie bitte zum schluss
fakt ist das höfesterben steht im
direkten zusammenhang mit der klimakrise
artensterben und diese krisen müssen wir
alle zusammen denken sonst ist es zu
spät dazu
eine monika spallek war das für die
grünen im nächste rednerin ist susanne
mittag sich die sprecherin für ernährung
und landwirtschaft der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die die damen
und herren dieses jahr ist das jahr der
entscheidung
und entscheidungen werden getroffen ja
das hat unsere bundeskanzler urlaubs
gestern schon mal gesagt und das stimmt
nicht nur im rahmen der generaldebatte
sondern auch im bereich ernährung und
landwirtschaft in diesem leider dieses
mal nur halbjährigen haushalt wir sind
ja schon im jahr fortgeschritten bei den
kurzfristigen haushaltsansätzen möchte
ich nochmal die unterstützung aufgrund
des ukraine krieges denn um mal dieser
dominanz der ewigen waffen debatten mal
was entgegenzusetzen
neben der zusammenarbeit mit anderen
ministerien und der koordinierungsstelle
mit der ukrainische landwirtschaft bzw
dem landwirtschaftsministerium und
weiteren institutionen werden jetzt 5
millionen zum beispiel auch für
tierarzneimittel in die ukraine
geschickt denn dort findet ihr auch noch
nutztierhaltung stadt sowie fünf
millionen für die unterstützung von
tierheim für die von flüchtlingen
mitgenommenen haustiere für
unterbringung und impfung das ist
eigentlich unwesentlicher teil des sehr
viel von ehrenamtlichen erledigt und das
bedarf der unterstützung
es ist ein sehr guter haushalts anschlag
weitere krisenhilfen an unsere landwirte
sind ja schon erwähnt worden die die 180
millionen und das ist bei weitem noch
nicht alles aber diese eta ansätze
führen auch zu einem themenbereich der
hier oftmals gar nicht erwähnt wird und
das sind sie internationalen maßnahmen
zur unterstützung der landwirtschaft und
der ernährungssicherung wird ein gesamt
etat von 65 millionen der im letzten
haushalt auch nicht ausgeschöpft worden
ist und da stellt sich natürlich die
frage ob die zukünftigen projekte den
globalen und individuellen
herausforderungen der unterschiedlichen
länder überhaupt gerecht werden und ob
sie ausreichend vernetzt sind und
abgestimmt mit den bereichen zum
beispiel der wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung mit der außenpolitik mit
weiteren internationalen projektträgern
und die frage kann jetzt schon
beantwortet werden sie sind es nicht so
fasst landwirtschaft und ernährung
vielleicht auch für einige überraschung
hier in den bereich eine mit dem bereich
der äußeren sicherheit aber auch in der
innere der sozialen und der
ernährungssicherheit ist landwirtschaft
und ernährung unterwegs dazu gehört zb
auch die zivile notfallreserve von
nahrungsmitteln deren konzept
überprüfungs bedürftig ist und sich die
frage stellt ob sie den derzeitigen
lagen die wir jetzt in den letzten
beiden jahren gehabt haben und noch
immer haben überhaupt noch entspricht
der etat von 27 millionen ist ja nicht
unerheblich aber seit 2017 als es mal
entworfen wurden hat sich die welt aber
einigermaßen verändert aber auch der
umgang zb mit einer gas mangel lage
welche bereiche der tierhaltung und
ernährungsversorgung sind denn wie
betroffen und wie sie sind sind sie zu
sichern habe ich auch noch eine kiefer
gehört und die in katastrophenfällen der
bestand zum beispiel in
tierhaltungsanlagen gerettet werden kann
erwähnt wäre hier nur zum beispiel im
rahmen der präventiven
hochwasserschutzes bei dem es ebenfalls
nachbesserungsbedarf gibt auch der
bereich landwirtschaft ist da nicht zu
unterschätzen ein beitrag der sozialen
und der nahrungssicherheit ist dabei
jahrelang etwas nachrangig betrachtet
wurden die fischerei aber das habe ich
mit begeisterung wahrgenommen sie ist
bislang mehrfach erwähnt worden das ist
mir wichtig landwirtschaft auch sie und
wir sind sehr froh dass neben
betriebshilfe aufgrund der derzeit
schwierigen lage auch zukunftsorientiert
förder möglichkeit zur umstellung auf
emissionsärmere antriebe aber auch für
aquakulturen unterschiedlicher konzepte
angeboten werden können und das ist die
zukunft der fischerei damit können sie
besser absichern und wir wollen damit
deutlich machen die fischerei ist uns
wichtig
bei allen maßnahmen in diesem bereich
sei es auf dem acker im wasser oder im
stall bei der verarbeitung bei der
lagerung oder vermarktung immer und
jetzt ist zukünftig ein ganz
entscheidender faktor die
digitalisierung sie wird in allen
bereichen von ernährung und
landwirtschaft gebraucht und hier findet
sich ein mittel auf wuchs auf über 51
millionen euro statt auch wo letzte mal
auch nicht alles abgerufen worden ist
aber für datenbanken autonome systeme
auswertung vereinfachte kontroll und
ehrlich gesagt das wollen wir auch eine
herzensangelegenheit die förderung zur
anschaffung grünen gestützte
wärmebildkameras zur kids rettung das
ist im letzten mal sehr oft massiv
angenommen worden dass es eine hilfe für
landwirte ihrer verpflichtung
nachzukommen vor der ersten markiere
wiese nach abgelegten kitzen abzusuchen
und ein großer dank an die vielen
hegeringe den ehrenamtliche arbeit in
frühen morgenstunden loslaufen und damit
die diesen absuchen und die landwirte
unterstützen ich war auch schon mal
dabei damit die hitze nicht von mir
werden erfasst werden und ja man kann
leider sagen zerstückelt werden auch
wenn es heute gegenteilige
pressemitteilung gab das ist veraltet
und so umfasst dieser haushalt nicht nur
große projekte kurzfristige hilfen
zukunftsorientierte pläne und vorhaben
sondern auch beiträge die leicht in den
hintergrund geraten wenn sie so klein
aber doch so wichtig sind herzlichen
dank
susanne mittag war das für die
spd-fraktion steht als nächstes spricht
christine sturm sie sitzt im ausschuss
für ernährung und landwirtschaft für die
unionsfraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nach 175
tagen im amt hat
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister özdemir
sich gebracht genau zwei gesetze
vorzulegen ansonsten gibt es außer
ankündigungen wenig keine
gesetzesentwürfe keine konkreten
konzepte alles bleibt an der oberfläche
die geduld unser land wurde neigt sich
so langsam dem ende zu herr minister
wann wollen sie endlich anfangen mit
ihrer arbeit oder wollen sie als ewiger
ankündigungsminister in die geschichte
eingehen in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
haben sie eine verbindliche tierhaltung
kennzeichnung noch für dieses jahr
angekündigt die auch transport und
schlachtung umfassen soll ebenso wollen
sie eine umfassende
herkunftskennzeichnung auf den weg
bringen dieses jahr ist allerdings schon
fast zur hälfte um und vorgelegt haben
sie bislang nichts stattdessen warten
sie bei der herkunftskennzeichnung auf
eine vorlage der eu kommission dabei
machen uns die nachbarländer frankreich
und österreich doch vor dass es auch
nationale lösungen gibt bei der haltungs
kennzeichnung las man in der presse
nichts beglücken dass er der erste ihre
ersten pläne gingen weg vom bereits im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel etablierten und
beim verbraucher hinreichend bekannten 1
notiert system hin zu einem system wie
bei der kennzeichnung wir nehmen mit
verwunderung zur kenntnis dass sie diese
idee inzwischen wieder zurückgezogen
haben offenbar sind sie sich innerhalb
ihrer koalition nicht einig wie sie
damit verfahren
unsere tierhalter brauchen aber gerade
jetzt die planungssicherheit also
liefern sie doch endlich und die unions
setzen uns für eine kombination aus
tierhaltung sind herkunftskennzeichnung
5 x d 1 nur die garantiert dass das tier
hier geboren aufgezogen gemästet
geschlachtet und verarbeitet wurde dies
wünschen sich unsere verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher sie möchten mehr
informationen und transparenz beim kauf
von lebensmitteln tierischer herkunft
und dazu gehören die haltung schlachtung
und transportbedingungen der tiere und
mit gutem gewissen fleisch verzehren zu
können sehr gern minister für 20 23
haben sie eine ernährung strategie
versprochen das ist sehr erfreulich aber
auch zu diesem vorhaben gibt es bislang
keine erkennbaren anzeichen von
aktivitäten man hört hierzu leider
nichts die ernährungspolitik ist heute
aber eine der maßgeblichen
querschnittsaufgaben in dieser
legislaturperiode sein zum einen sollten
solltest dir übergreifend entwickelt
werden zum anderen müssen auch praktiker
wissenschaftler und akteure aus allen
relevanten bereichen berufen
altersgruppen eingebunden werden wenn
sie damit nicht bald anfangen dann wird
es dieses wird es dies auch bis nächstes
jahr nicht geben
meine damen und herren wir sind uns alle
einig darin einig dass gesunde ernährung
für alle zugänglich sein muss deshalb
braucht es angemessene rahmenbedingungen
und verbraucherinformationen für alle
zielgruppen wir in der union werden
nicht akzeptieren dass es in deutschland
einen speiseplan nach dem gehaltszettel
gibt gerade in zeiten ohnehin drastisch
steigende lebenshaltungskosten kommt es
auf eine soziale ausgewogenheit der
ernährungspolitik doch an
dabei wollen wir niemanden erziehen oder
bevormunden sondern der mündige
verbraucher soll selbst entscheiden was
auf den tisch kommt mit dem niedrigst
geruch haben wir im november 2020 ein
erweitert
visuelle nährwertkennzeichnung für
fertig lebensmittel in deutschland
eingeführt die den verbrauchern eine
gute hilfestellung bei der
lebensmittelauswahl bietet seither haben
sich 300 die firmen mit 577 morgen für
eine verwendung registriert das ist zu
begrüßen und weiter auszubauen
lassen sie mich noch auf den ländlichen
auf die längst region zu sprechen kommen
rund 90 prozent der fläche in
deutschland sind ländlich geprägt rund
57 prozent der bevölkerung leben auf dem
land ländliche räume sind lebensraum und
wirtschaftsstandort zugleich die ampel
hat aber hier andere prioritäten warum
sonst setzt sich hier den rotstift an
6 millionen euro weniger soll ist
zukünftig für den bundeshaushalt für das
bundesprogramm ländliche entwicklung
geben kann benutzt der minister das
thema macht auf mich lieblich lieber
mehr politik für großstädte anstatt
gutes leben und arbeiten auf dem land zu
fördern
meine damen und herren regionale
daseinsvorsorge ist eine
gemeinschaftsaufgabe wir brauchen mehr
digitalisierung in der fläche damit neun
digitale technologien können
lebensmittel umweltfreundlicher werden
es geht um sparsame ausbringen von
dünger und pflanzenschutzmittel aber
auch und daniel züchtungsmethoden für
widerstandsfähige und ertragreicher
pflanzen innovation statt produktions
verzicht ist hier die zukunft
zu starken ländlichen räumen gehört aber
auch die unterstützung des ehrenamts
gerade in den letzten wochen hat sich
angesichts der vielen ukrainischen
flüchtlinge eindrucksvoll gezeigt wie
unerlässlich ehrenamtliches engagement
in den gemeinden war und ist
vor allem auch die tafeln sind an dieser
stelle zu nennen rund 60.000
ehrenamtliche haben wir bundesweit die
hier unverzichtbare arbeit leisten
leider haben während der korona pandemie
viele von ihnen aus angst vor ansteckung
ihre arbeit ruhen lassen das haben wir
vor kurzem auch die mitarbeiter dort
half waiblinger tafel meinem wahlkreis
berichtet zeitgleich sind aber immer
mehr menschen auf die tafel angewiesen
hinzu kommen steigende betriebskosten
deshalb sind wir in der union der
ansicht dass wir gerade hier jetzt die
tafel unterstützen müssen damit sie
weiterhin ihre wichtige arbeit leisten
können
sehr gerne minister die zeiten sind
ernst echte lösung statt ideologie täten
unserem land sehr gut deshalb setzen sie
sich mit dem betroffenen mit den
landwirten mit allen beteiligten einen
tisch bauern müssen wirtschaften können
und nicht in auflagen erstickt werden es
ist höchste zeit für ein ernährungs
gipfel angesichts der drängenden fragen
von dem wir stehen denn die meine vor
regen völlig zu recht festgestellt haben
der krieg in der ukraine wird sich nicht
noch unsere lebensmittelpreise außer
gefährdet insbesondere die
ernährungssicherheit auf der ganzen welt
vielen dank
und der nächste redner dr gärung kleben
zocker fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist usus dass auf jedem lebensmittel
dass wir erwerben sehr deutlich und
transparent erkennbar ist wie lange es
haltbar ist wie viel kalorien ist
beinhaltet wie viel eiweiß wie viele
kohlehydrate wie viel kalorien es
enthält aber bei tierischen
lebensmitteln verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen ist nicht erkennbar wie und vor
allem wo das tier gehalten wurde wo es
geboren wurde wo es gezogen wurde
hierüber wollen wir und werden wir
endlich transparenz herstellen denn
meine sehr vereinnahmen und herren mit
nichts kann der verbraucher einen
größeren beitrag leisten für mehr
tierwohl für mehr klimaschutz für mehr
nachhaltigkeit und viel mehr
biodiversität als durch die bewusste
entscheidung für lebensmittel die in
deutschland entstanden sind denn man
eine sehr fern damen und herren in kaum
einem anderen land dieser welt sind die
haltungs standards so hoch wie in
deutschland und wir sollten stolz darauf
sein dass wir das auch endlich auf den
lebensmittel anbringen zweite kollegen
stattdessen tut die union durchs land
und erklärt dass die ampel einfach nur
die pläne der vorgängerregierung
umsetzen müsste und dann wäre sie schon
vieles erreicht
ja herr kollege stegemann bestätigt das
noch mal ich sage ihnen eins wenn das
politisch alles so einfach wer lieber
albert stegemann dann wissen wir doch
alle in diesem nach hause dann hättet
ihr das doch gemacht aber es ist eben
nicht so einfach ihr würde doch nicht
sozusagen pläne auf den weg bringen und
dann gönnerhaft der nächsten regierung
es überlassen diese probleme oder diese
pläne umzusetzen
das ist politischer politisches harakiri
wäre das und deswegen wird sehr deutlich
es ist eben nicht so einfach und der
teufel steckt im detail ich sage ihnen
eins kein anderer berufsstand über
albert stegemann ist in den letzten
jahren so häufig mit versprechungen
überzogen worden die dann aber nachher
von der politik nicht gehalten wurde und
die quasi im schlaf mal spielt gar nicht
und politik wer welche farbe darum geht
es begann ich habe gesagt die politik
insgesamt politik insgesamt kein kein
berufsstand ist in den vergangenen
jahren und jahrzehnten mit mehr
versprechungen überzogen worden die
nachher wie staub zusammengefallen sind
und deswegen haben wir gemeinsam die
verantwortung eben nicht rauszugehen mit
finanzierungsmodellen die am ende doch
nicht tragen mit zu sagen wenn landwirte
vielleicht über 20 jahre ich entstanden
umbauen eine finanzierung machen und
eine gewähr brauchen dass keine neuen
standards dazu kommen mit instrumenten
die eben nur über sieben jahre eine
entsprechende garantie geben und
deswegen sage ich kann es ausdrücklich
es funktioniert nicht mit einer
mehrwertsteuer die ja per definition
schon zweck ungebunden ist ganz gezielt
bestimmte dinge in unserem lande
zuschauer wie zb einen stadtumbau das
ist mit zitronen gehandelt und es seien
sie doch bitte so ehrlich das den
menschen auch zu sagen verehrte
kolleginnen kollegen
zweiter punkt
eine abgabe könnte man ja auch einführen
eine abgabe das gestehe ich zu die ist
per se ja erst mal gebunden an bestimmte
aufgaben aber sag ich ganz ausdrücklich
als vertreter der freien demokraten
gewissen genau wie es mit der
zweckgebundenheit einer abgabe
tatsächlich im politischen alltag
aussieht also der solidaritätszuschlag
der ist vor 30 jahren mal auf den weg
gebracht worden waren ganz gezielt die
besonderen herausforderungen der
deutschen einheit finanzielle abbilden
wollte und wir wissen das seit
jahrzehnten dieser obolus schon lange
nicht mehr in die neuen bundesländer
fließen deswegen ist auch hier die frage
doch zu stellen ob das tatsächlich eine
verlässliche perspektive ist
verlässliche rahmenbedingungen genau das
ist es was die landwirte brauchen und
was bislang von ihrer ehemaligen auf dem
tisch nicht sind reine
lippenbekenntnisse und nichts was
wirklich tatsächlich über 20 jahre
tragen würde und das muss an dieser
stelle auch mal sehr deutlich sagen
und vor allem würden zusätzliche steuern
oder abgaben die das uhr problem noch
verschlimmern und das uhr problem ist
darin zu sehen dass eben lebensmittel
dem ausland zu niedrigeren standards
erzeugt wurde innerhalb des europäischen
binnenmarkt es auch günstiger angeboten
werden können und die die in deutschland
produziert wurden einen höheren preis
abverlangen und wenn man jetzt mit einer
pauschalen steuer oder abgabe hingehen
würde und beides verteuern würde würde
relativ das deutsche lebensmittel noch
zusätzlich verteuert werden das wird
nicht dazu führen dass mehr menschen
tatsächlich zum lebensmittel ast und
deutschland stand entstanden ist greifen
würden was landwirte wirklich brauchen
wer ihnen wirklich eine perspektive in
deutschland geben will er kämpft für die
angleichung von produktionsstarts
innerhalb des europäischen binnenmarktes
der kämpft der kämpft für einen auflagen
moratorien damit eine investition sich
tatsächlich auch am markt amortisieren
kann und er sagt dem verbraucher dass er
seinen hehren versprechungen auch
tatsächlich endlich taten folgen lassen
und er auch tatsächlich zu dem
lebensmittel greifen muss dass er
einfordert verehrte kolleginnen oder
kollegen damit würde man landwirtschaft
hat technik nutzen kommt die stadt
abschluss ganz ausdrücklich werte frau
präsident danke für den hinweis es ist
glaube ich recht deutlich geworden dass
wir in den letzten monaten das korrektiv
gewesen körper damit letzter suns das
ist der letzte satz ich hab den gerade
erst angefangen immer dann den finger
erhoben haben wenn tatsächlich zu viel
ideologie und zu wenig pragmatismus
existiert und dass wir über die nächsten
300 weiter so war es ein langer letzter
satz
von mark war es bundestagsvize
präsidentin erinnert hier nochmal an die
redezeit ist ist ja eine recht volle
woche für die abgeordneten das ist in
der haushaltswoche immer so mit den
vielen einzelplänen bitter hagel kiel
spricht jetzt für die spd
kollegen wir stehen für eine ernährungs
wende das heißt eine ernährungspolitik
die auf gesundheit und nachhaltigkeit
setzt und die verbraucherbildung
verbraucher stärker unterstützt daher
haben wir im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart dass wir bis 2023
insbesondere mit blick auf die kinder
gemeinsam mit allen akteuren eine
ernährungs strategie erarbeiten die eine
gesunde klima schonende und
umweltschonende ernährung zum ziel hat
das ist uns als spd ein herzensanliegen
und dafür stehe haben wir sehr lange
zeit gekämpft
wir haben keine kenntnis defizit sondern
ein handlungs defizit
wissenschaftler und ärztinnen ärzte
fachverbände krankenkassen
verbraucherschützerin um
verbraucherschützer fordern schon lange
ein umdenken in der ernährungspolitik
auch die aktuelle forsa umfrage zudem
folgende corona krise bei kindern hat
nochmals deutlich gemacht dass wir keine
erkenntnis sondern ein handlungs defizit
haben und dass wir dringend eine
ernährung ratti gebrauchen 16 der kinder
und jugendlichen sind dicker geworden in
der zeit mit corona bei kindern im alter
von zehn bis zwölf jahren sind es sogar
kinder und jugendliche aus
einkommensschwachen familien sind
doppelt so oft betroffen
als kinder und jugendliche aus er
einkommensstarken familien also hier ist
das verhältnis 23 zu 12
27 prozent der kinder und jugendlichen
haben angegeben häufiger zu süß waren
als zuvor zuzugreifen
deswegen freut es mich besonders dass im
einzelplan 10 unter dem maßnahmen zur
förderung ausgewogene ernährung mittel
zur verfügung gestellt werden die
ausschließlich für die ernährung
strategie ausgegeben werden müssen das
ist ein wichtiger und richtiger schritt
um ein anschub für die umsetzung unseres
koalitionsvorhaben dies soll natürlich
in den nächsten jahren noch stark
ausgebaut werden was ist für eine
ernährung strategie wichtig erstens das
essen beziehungsweise
lebensmittelangebot zu verbessern die
reduktion strategie zucker salz und
ungesunde fette im verarbeiteten
lebensmitteln mit lebensmitteln wirksam
zu reduzieren
hier ist ja die vorgänger ministerien er
nur bei auf freiwilliger basis gesetzt
verbindliche ernährungs profile nach den
whu kriterien verbindliche einführung
der standards der deutschen gesellschaft
für ernährung in der
gemeinschaftsverpflegung
zweitens zugang zu gesunden essen durch
positive anreize und gesunde ernährung
umgebung für alle erleichtern an kinder
gerichtete werbung für ungesunde
produkte wollen wir verbieten
gleichzeitig ist ein finanzieller anreiz
für gesunde lebensmittel
das heißt auch eine
mehrwertsteuersenkung für obst gemüse
und hülsenfrüchte käme in betracht und
dafür ein bürger mehrwertsteuersatz für
ungesunde produkte als ausgleich
das bewusstsein für gesunde und
nachhaltige ernährungsweise müssen wir
durch mehr transparenz und bessere
aufklärung stärken ernährungsbildung an
schulen und kitas
aufklärungskampagnen eu-weites court
kennzeichnungspflicht und ein kriterien
für ein staatliches nachhaltigkeits
label die landwirtschaftliche erzeugung
muss der kann den erfordernissen einer
nachhaltigen ernährungsweise
ausgerichtet werden zum beispiel durch
stärkung der eiweißpflanzen strategie
die maßgaben der zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft wurden schon von meinem
kollegen matthias miersch erklärt die
müssen wir nur umsetzen und wir brauchen
nichts neues entwickeln nun ist es am
bbl dass sie eben diesen entwurf einer
ernährung strategie vorlegen und die zur
verfügung gestellten mittel für dieses
jahr ausschütten zwei wichtige punkte
fehlen mir allerdings in diesem haushalt
das ist einmal der bereich der schul und
gemeinschaftsverpflegung wo wir auch
eine anschubfinanzierung brauchen für
die modellregionen außerdem für eine
aufklärungskampagne für verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher zur vorteil einer
ernährung mit pflanzlichen eiweiß
alternativen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die uhr tickt die kosten für
die folgen von ungesunder ernährung
müssen wir alle tragen auch in zukunft
und kinder und jugendliche sind unsere
zukunft darum ist es an uns dies nun
endlich umzusetzen
ich danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
rita hagl kiel war das für die spd
fraktion ist
christina johannes schröder sie sitzt
auch im ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe gästen für springs
first gestern war tag welttag der
bäuerin und das sind gute anlass um
einfach mal danke zu sagen danke für
lebensmittelsicherheit
lebensmittelqualität und harte arbeit
bevor ich auf den haushalt eingehen herr
lief es ist mir seit ihrer rede ein
anliegen etwas zu sagen afrika ist ein
sehr großer kontinent mit sehr
unterschiedlichen staaten mit sehr
unterschiedlicher agrarstruktur und ich
habe das gefühl es interessiert sie nur
wenn es gegen biodiversität geht
christlich das ist ja die union was
fordern die kirchen aufbau bäuerlicher
strukturen
hunger langfristig zu bekämpfen sagt mit
vielfalt genau das ist das was gefordert
wird in hunger dauerhaft zu bekämpfen
aber davon höre ich bei ihnen nichts in
der debatte
wir hören ihnen ja die ganze zeit zu und
wir machen ein statusbericht der
strukturwandel in der landwirtschaft das
wachsen und weichen und das höfesterben
all das haben sie ihre politik der union
verursacht es gibt drei jahre es gab
ernteeinbußen es gab mäuseplage es gab
den verlust von wasser speicherkapazität
und wurden es gab überschwemmungen all
das sind ursachen der klimakrise unter
den landwirten ganz konkret leiden und
ihre antwort die gibt es darauf nicht
sie war sie machen einfach die augen
dafür zu wie kleine kinder wenn sie
etwas nicht sehen wollen hier beim
menschen leid und dem kostendruck den
ihre politik verursacht hat sie haben so
viel vertrauen zerstört dass es jetzt
ein langer weg wird den aufzubauen und
wir haben uns mit diesem haushalt auf
den weg gemacht
es ist wichtig dass wir einen soliden
pfad bauen der mehr als vier jahre hält
und dass wir fangen mit der tierhaltung
scan zeichnung an einer staatlichen
einer verbindlichen es geht weiter mit
dem bau und emissionsrechte es geht auch
darum eine investition für tierwohl
stelle zu schaffen eine milliarde dies
im haushalt eingestellt und wir brauchen
eine dauerhafte finanzierung für diese
tierhaltung
wir brauchen diese finanzierung muss
dafür sorgen dass eben die bäuerinnen
und bauern sich auf diesem weg machen
und ihre tierhaltung langfristig
umstellen wir haben auch eine wir haben
auch noch einen preis als posten der
hier viele fans hat das ist die
küstenfischerei sie wurde heute schon
mehrfach erwähnt und wir kennen das
schöne bild der fischkutter in den häfen
wir empfinden das als touristisches
highlight aber oft stecken familien
generation und tradition dahinter und
ohne die zehn millionen euro im haushalt
würden viele dieser küstenfischerei
diesen sommer nicht mehr erleben
aufgrund des gestiegenen stifter dieses
einen weiteren punkt möchte ich einen
hai leiten dass es die 16 millionen euro
für die eiweißpflanzen strategie die wir
erhöhen denn das ist etwas ganz
wesentliches einmal weil wir natürlich
viel mehr heimisches futter für tiere
brauchen
aber auch wir menschen brauchen vielmehr
eiweißfutter und bei uns in
niedersachsen agrarland nummer 1 da gibt
es einen großen hersteller der sucht
händeringend nach produzentinnen für
eiweißpflanzen weil es so viele
ersatzprodukte gibt die die menschen
essen wollen und das ist großartig weil
es eine klimafreundliche chance einfach
den bedarf an narben zu stillen und eben
die resilienz die ökonomische und
ökologische residenz zu stärken
ich freue mich auf den gemeinsamen weg
mit den wellen und dem bmw l vielen dank
und der kollege max straubinger cdu csu
fraktion ist der nächste redner
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin der die kolleginnen und
kollegen am ende dieser debatte kommt
noch die frau kollegin noch aber dann
ist ja die abstimmung auch über den
haushalt muss man mit feststellen dass
letztendlich die zukunftsperspektiven
wird die landwirte in deutschland nicht
besser geworden sind der bundesminister
hat in seiner regierungserklärung am 14
1/22 formuliert es gibt darum dass die
landwirt die wertschätzung erfahren ich
kann diese wertschätzung in diesen
haushalt für die landwirte nicht
erkennen herr bundes
oder verstehen sie wertschätzung
darunter dass die
bundesmittel gekürzt werden wird die
landwirtschaftliche unfallversicherung
und damit die preise in der
landwirtschaftlichen
unfallversicherungen die belastungen für
die landwirte um 17 prozent steigen
werden wenn das ihre wertschätzung ist
der landwirtschaft gut dann ist das ihr
mantra aber nicht das unternehmen wir
verstehen dies so nicht
verstehen sie
wertschätzung unter kürzungen für
zukunftsinvestitionen in der
landwirtschaft wir verstehen das anders
die wertschätzung hiermit in unserem
lande für die bäuerinnen und bauern es
geht nämlich um unterstützung für die
bäuerinnen und bauern und wenn
verschiedenste redner der koalition
planungssicherheit mit angemahnt haben
so können sich und zu müssen diese
planungssicherheit auch erarbeitet
werden jetzt wurde vielfältig ist immer
der fingerzeig auf uns als cdu csu in
der vergangenheit 16 jahre verantwortung
gezeigt aber herr kollege mir schwer hat
es verhindert dass planungssicherheit
für moderne stelle geschaffen wurden
wäre es war doch die spd-fraktion in der
vergangenheit die uns daran gehindert
hat das offene stelle luftige stelle
hier auch in ländlichen raum errichtet
wurden werden hätten können das ist ihre
bilanz und jetzt heute so zu jammern als
er das kann wirklich nicht sein werte
damen und herren
ich frage mich wo war auch die
unterstützung
für die obstbauern für die gemüsebauern
des landwirtschaftsministers die frau
kollegin dr spanisch hat vorhin auch
tränenreich also dargelegt dass
erdbeerfelder umgepflügt werden dass
also spargelfelder nicht mehr abgeerntet
werden können und dergleichen mehr
wo war die unterstützung für eine
übergangslösung bei der mindestlohn bei
der beschaffung des mindestlohns von 12
euro es ist ja das konnte aber und da
müssen sich auch die landwirte darauf
einstellen wo war die unterstützung des
ministers des bittens der gemüsebauern
um die verlängerung der 70 tage regelung
auf 102 tage wo war da die unterstützung
des ministers und ihrer grünen fraktion
also es geht nicht an pradé erspare hier
tränenreich also den wettbewerb zu
bejammern und dass die deutschen
verbraucher
letztendlich auf die billigeren produkte
hinlangen und hingreifen und damit
letztendlich die produktion in
deutschland verschwinden wird das ist
letztendlich das ergebnis ihrer politik
die sie betreiben
und diese politik diese politik ist zur
ideologie geleitet und es merkt man ganz
besonders in der bewältigung oder
beziehungsweise nicht bewältigung der
aktuellen
verbrecherischen situation genug rallye
die wir erleben müssen durch russland
und jetzt bedeutet dass hinterher dann
die menschen hungern werden müssen heute
laufen durch die ticker 300 millionen
menschen werden von hunger letztendlich
oder oder leiden möglicherweise hunger
in der zukunft ja das ist er gerade
auftrag an uns an die europäische union
an deutschland hier einen beitrag zu
leisten dass mehr produziert wird in
unserem land und wir
sind uns völlig einig mit den kollegen
der fdp nicht fragen was macht die fdp
die fdp in dieser koalition sie sollten
sich ja dahinter klemmen damit in der
europäischen union diese bundesregierung
endlich initiativen ergreift dass
zukünftig die flächenstilllegung
2023 nicht stattfinden wird von 4% was
tut sie wo ist ihr antrag wo ist ihr
engagement ich kann nicht erkennen also
muss man die haben mit sehen also dass
die bäuerinnen und bauern die warten
drauf wir stellen diese anträge sie sind
in der regel immer dabei diese
abzulehnen also wo ist ihre stimme für
die bäuerinnen und bauern ich kann sie
nicht ich kann sie nicht erkennen also
herr kollege hocker und
bundesminister hat in seiner
regierungserklärung auch gesagt also das
gute grundlagen da sind für die zukunft
der landwirtschaft zeuge x die
zukunftskommission natürlich und viele
andere dinge die schon bereitet worden
symbol her kommission unter lud das ist
alles da nur in den letzten halben jahr
und ist nichts gearbeitet worden und
letztendlich trifft fahrt fast das wort
zu dass der kollege hocker muss
dargelegt hat
der kollege hocker hat formuliert es hat
in den letzten sechs monaten seit
bestehen dieser bundesregierung nicht
zum einen einzigen gesetzgeberischen
nationalen alleingang geführt diesem
anliegen haben sie mittels einen neuen
sinn bekommen nämlich weil die regierung
gar nichts getan habt also das ist
natürlich mit dabei in diesem sinne
werden hier wären
[Applaus]
das war der letzte satz und damit kommen
wir zur letzten rednerin in dieser
debatte und es ist jetzt auch ja wieder
so sehen ist dass die zuschauertribünen
wieder am mit zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern gefüllt werden also hier doch
einige mehr als nur die abgeordnete
dieser debatte hier vor ort folgen
die stimmen nach einer
rückwärtsgewandten agrarpolitik sie
werden wieder lauter doch wir dürfen die
bestehenden krisen nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen es geht nicht um schnelle
lösungen denn die klima und
biodiversität krise gefährdet unsere
lebensgrundlage nur auf gesunden böden
können wir auch langfristig gesunde
lebensmittel im raum
müssen wir uns weil die waren
volkswirtschaftlichen kosten unseres
ernährungssystem es ehrlich machen denn
die preise an der ladenkasse sprechen
nicht immer die wahrheit zurück
entstehen durch nitrit nitrat im
grundwasser versteckte kosten die von
der gesellschaft an anderer stelle
bezahlt werden müssen wie durch erhöhte
wasserpreise am dienstag hatten wir in
unserer ag ernährung und landwirtschaft
herrn professor strohschneider den
vorsitzenden der zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft zu besuch ich möchte auch
noch einmal deutlich machen wir stehen
auch in der jetzigen krise zu dem
historischen kompromiss und
schlussfolgerungen der
zukunftskommission
die vermeidung selber nutzen unserer
natürlichen ressourcen muss sich für die
landwirtinnen betriebswirtschaftlich
lohnen denn die landwirtschaft ist
systemrelevant die transformation ist
unsere gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
mit diesem haushalt unterstützen wir die
landwirtschaft konkret der ökolandbau
ist ein wichtiger faktor regionale sowie
widerstandsfähige wertschöpfungsketten
und bleibt auch in krisenzeiten ein
wesentliches element einer
zukunftsfähigen landwirtschaft in
deutschland durch die streichung des
buchstaben n beim bundesprogramm
ökologischer landbau und andere formen
nachhaltiger landwirtschaft ja ein
langer titel kurz köln schafft die ampel
im haushalt einen eigenen fördertopf nur
für den ökolandbau
somit werden in diesem jahr
32,5 millionen euro zielgerichtet für
den forschungsbedarf des ökolandbaus
bereitstehen um das ziel 30 prozent öko
landbau bis 2030 zu erreichen ein
weiteres thema das mich bewegt um zu
welchem am 16 mai eine sonder
agrarministerkonferenz stattfand ist
unser wald die situation ist ernst auch
in diesem frühjahr hat es in vielen
regionen zu wenig gelegt wird laut dem
deutschen wetterdienst gehörte der märz
zu den trockensten seit der
wetteraufzeichnung die ansprüche an
unsere wälder hinzugenommen bedarf des
rohstoffs holz beitrag zum klimaschutz
förderung der biodiversität und
natürlich der erholungsort für uns alle
wir entwickeln ein system zur
honorierung dieser
ökosystemleistungen mit dem wir die
kommunalen und privaten waldbesitzern
bei dem unter strom bau unterstützen
werden wir wollen anreize für die
verbesserung der wald leistungen
schaffen unsere wälder brauchen zwar
dringend wasser doch die gelder dürfen
eben nicht im gießkannenprinzip verteilt
werden eile ist geboten
sehr geehrte damen und herren dass wir
in dieser woche diesen haushalt
verabschieden können wir die in freier
geheimer gleicher unmittelbarer und
allgemeiner wahl gewählten ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit
komm wir ziehen in den krieg wir sind
mehr als du glaubst wir sind schlafende
riesen aber jetzt stehen wir auch sagen
die sängerinnen von koriander am letzten
samstag auf dem marktplatz in neustadt
an der weinstraße den appell von udo
lindenberg wir wollten ein fest für die
demokratie feiern weil vor 190 jahren
demokratinnen und demokraten aus ganz
europa aufs hambacher schloss gezogen
sind der beginn eines langen prozesses
zur freiheit frieden und demokratie und
das hambacher schloss ist als wiege der
deutschen demokratie in die geschichte
eingegangen doch aus dem fröhlichen fest
am wochenende wurde ein aufmarsch von
den weiß gekleideten selbsternannten
freiheits aktivistinnen deren ignoranten
aggressiven prügeleien dazu führten dass
beispielsweise die stände vom bündnis
gegen rechts und der gedenkstätte für ns
opfer ihre teilnahme am fest abbrechen
mussten und familien eben nicht mit
ihren kindern hinauf hinauf zum schloss
ziehen konnten aber jetzt stehen wir
auch und zwar mit der fambacher
intervention die sie alle mit
unterzeichnen können um sich deutlich
gegen die vereinnahmung unserer
demokratie geschichte von rechts zu
stellen oder um es mit den worten du
achim gaus zu sagen dem ersten
preisträger des hambacher freiheits
kreises wir lassen uns unsere symbole
der deutschen demokratiebewegung nicht
von den feinden der demokratie cup haben
ich will schließen mit einem dank an die
schubert schule in neustadt wo schüler
innen lehrer innen und eltern jeden tag
unsere demokratie leben und dafür mit
dem johann philipp abresch preis
ausgezeichnet wurden wir sind schlafende
riesen aber jetzt stehen wir auf
und ich beende die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan 10
bundesministerium für ernährung und
landwirtschaft in der ausschuss fassung
hier liegt ein änderungsantrag der cdu
csu auf drucksache 20 51 vor in diesem
änderungsantrag
fordert die union wieder von den
abgeordneten noch mal erläutert dass die
zuschüsse zur landwirtschaftlichen
unfallversicherung
erhöht werden fd und union stimmen
diesem antrag zu
die koalitionsfraktionen
enthaltungen das ist nicht der fall dann
ist der änderungsantrag mit den stimmen
der koalitionsfraktionen abgelehnt
wer stimmt für den jetzt stimmt über den
einzelplan 10 in der ausschuss fassung
wer stimmt da geht mehr stimmt dafür
das sind die kolleginnen kollegen der
koalitionsfraktionen der stimmt dagegen
der rest des hauses die
schlussabstimmung erfolgt ja dann erst
morgen